[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
only 24 hours
yes
this is going to pierce your mustache
off
wait what is crowd choice voting for the
club
[Applause]
hello everyone and happy holidays
welcome to the stream you guys just saw
a new trailer for outcasters which is a
new game from stadia games and
entertainment
it's out today ready to play you'll be
seeing much more of it on this stream
which is the very first
outcasters live stream ever
but first things first if you don't know
me i am wwe superstar xavier woods aka
austin creed and the host of the
greatest youtube channel of all time up
up down
down and today i've teamed up with
stadia for this holiday live stream why
because i love games i love all kinds of
games and i think it's awesome
that with stadia i can play all sorts of
games on all sorts of screens and it's a
huge deal for me honestly
because back in my day in our previous
life
i'd get the chance to travel around the
world to different countries different
cities every night so i spend a whole
lot of time on the road
traveling from show to show as a wwe
superstar so
when i wasn't kicking people in the face
or being kicked in the face myself
i'm playing video games so the fact that
i can play stadia on my phone backstage
or
in the tv in my hotel room is honestly
just great
and uh where are we at right here and
this stadia controller
oh it's so sweet but you don't even need
this to play
you can use the controls you already
have but but i do really like this and
there's a wasabi one it's like a light
green it's
just kissed but this is a live stream so
we're gonna do more than just talk about
games we're gonna play them with
you live whoever you are wherever you're
watching from and however you like to
play thank you for joining us
it's the holidays and it's a time for
hanging out remotely obviously
with others and having fun and so today
we're going to be hanging out and
talking all things stadia live
we've got a fantastic co-host who's
going to be joining us here soon
so to give a quick overview of what
you're going to get today we've got some
announcements from stadia games and
entertainment
we have three new trailers to check out
and watch together three more
a special guest from ubisoft is going to
be stopping by to talk about an amazing
game that just launched on stadium today
immortals phoenix rising and we have a
ton of games to play
and while we're at it we'll show you
some of the new exclusive things you can
do
only with stadia really cool stuff that
changes the way you experience your
favorite game
so i've given you some information and
now it's time for a little bit of fun
i'm gonna bring on
my co-host the incredible the talented
we have ladies and gentlemen katie
wilson what an introduction
thank you austin i'm really excited to
be here today
and i'm so excited to be playing some
games this is gonna be fun
yes i'm pumped uh i'm glad you're my my
sherpa on this journey
today because uh because you're
fantastic and i feel like i'm
probably not gonna win around if i get
in but we'll see what happens nah
nah we'll see we'll see i'm sure you'll
be great yeah
fingers crossed well as you're going to
set up the first game i'm going to give
some more information so we'll see in a
little bit katie
cool see you soon all right okay so
before we get into all that let's take a
closer look at the awesome new ways you
can have fun with games on stadia
picture this you ever been watching a
live stream on youtube and just want to
reach
into the screen and just make things a
lot harder for that streamer or make
things a lot easier for them
you just change things now you can now
this is one of the coolest things about
stadia is what it lets you do with games
it's
stuff that brings players and streamers
together in these amazing ways and these
features kind of
bend the rules for what's possible with
games especially when it comes to
interacting with youtubers
so first we've got what's called crowd
choice so while you're watching your
favorite streamer on youtube you can
vote and change the game
in real time as it's being played so if
you're watching me or one of your other
favorite youtubers play outcasters
you can take control of the game and
choose our loadout options so you're
very much in control then we've got
crowdplay beta
so if you're watching me take on
ghostface and dead by daylight and you
think you can do better
go ahead and press the crowd play button
and find out and this one's honestly my
favorite because you know
that you've been watching a stream and
someone says hey come play this game
with me and it's like oh well now we got
to exchange
friend codes and go through all this
hoopla now
forget all that you'll be able to join
the game as we're streaming
and play with or against us while the
whole world watches you just press the
button while you're watching the stream
and you're in
and since it's still in beta crowdplay
works now on laptops and desktops and
it's also coming to mobile in 2021
and it works with any enabled stream and
i i for one i can't wait to try those
but
let's see i don't have to and you don't
have to because in just a second we're
going to see how crowd choice and crowd
play beta work
by playing a new game that uses both of
these new features but first
we got a quick announcement from stadia
games and entertainment because the
publisher
uh the the publisher excuse me uh behind
stadium's exclusive titles and they've
been working tirelessly
to bring more brand new experiences to
stadia and they will be announcing a
partnership with the acclaimed
indie publisher thunderful let's go
thunderful is going to be joining the
ranks of stadia's many amazing partners
and it's going to be so exciting to see
the wild experiences
that they bring to stadia next all right
i've given you information
you absorb that take it in osmosis style
and we're going to bring back
katie wilson hey play some games thanks
for having me back
i'm so pumped to play some games austin
how about you
i am so ready i'm so prepared
yep all right well we saw the trailer
earlier so why don't we fire up some
outcasters
outcasters is the colorful chaotic
competitive shooter from stadia games
and entertainment
and it just launched a few minutes ago
but since it's stadia
guys we don't have to wait for a
download because we can play
right now uh if everyone just wants to
give a quick refresh to their browser
you're going to
see that below the chat there's going to
be a button
and all you have to do is click that
button
and with crowdplay beta you can actually
join my squad
right now let's start our very first
ever outcasters live stream
what do you say i like this i like this
katie i love it
because the fact that people are just
simply watching this live stream and all
i have to do is press a button in order
to join
this game i know it blows my mind
i know and uh what's really cool is that
with crowd play beta uh
you you don't even have to i mean
without casters you don't even have to
buy it it comes for
free with stadio pro uh and it's just
one small part of what stadia pro is all
about you get a
ton more free games and special
discounts on stuff you buy on stadia
and you don't even have to have a stadia
pro account
you can create one today for free and
you'll get a one month free trial of
stadia pro and you can start
you know slinging those curve shots in
outcasters
right away guys you can visit stadia.com
for all of the information
and like i said refresh that browser
click on that button below the chat and
come join me right now
right now live katie i i just to make
sure that i'm
hearing this clearly you keep saying
this word which it's probably my
favorite word
uh f-r-e-e free you said free about
free yes that is the best
part outcaster comes free with stadia
pro
oh we almost have a full queue
in there oh i'm excited uh oh
this game just came out so everyone's
gonna be relatively new so this is gonna
be a really fun way
to experience the game all right we have
a full party are we ready oh let's go
let's go let's do it i'm so ready i'm
also
uh i may have slid in myself so good
there we go well you know what uh right
when we get into the match
i'm gonna call on everyone out there to
help me strategize because
i'm gonna be putting up a crowd choice
poll
it'll pop all you have to do
is vote and you guys can actually choose
the abilities
that i can use in this first match
which is so cool so when you're watching
your favorite streamer
you can actually help make decisions for
them
you can choose their abilities you could
choose the characters they play as you
can choose the stories or missions they
go on
you can help curate the experience and
uh
it's just a full interactive experience
with your favorite streamer or your
friends
it's so cool here we go oh man we got
started okay
get ready because that poll is gonna pop
up in just a second
and i need you guys to pick a good
ability hopefully push
all right vote now vote now all right
oh oh it's between push oh
push is good oh okay oh we're getting a
lot coming in for
oh fleming who won it who won it all
right come on
oh we got a lot for push all right it
looks like push one
that's exciting because with push i can
actually
uh use that to push
my enemies away from me
uh also so into some trouble people that
are watching
this so you're about to see us
annihilate everyone in this
is that is that uh is that true just so
it's clear
yeah so you move around with the left
analog stick and then you aim with the
right
analog stick and then you can bank your
shot so mid shot you can point
your the stick or the right analog stick
a certain direction and it'll curve that
way
oh and i got pop katie katie you got me
oh
sorry oh we're on opposite teams this is
good uh well
also uh when when you actually do take
out an enemy
they'll have a little heart there and
that'll help you regain another whoa
life oh wow it's
three nothing get out of here
oh no oh no not again
yeah there we go there we go this is
terrifying
this is great we did it we're going to
get out of here katie get out of here
oh sorry corey all right where's austin
should i go oh there he is
no get away from me sorry i'm sorry
again again
sorry again i'm really sorry there uh
did you wait i get it i get it
okay okay
she got me so so everybody knows we
played this what an hour ago
katie wasn't anywhere near as this good
she got me
she pulled shark to me i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i've been working hard been working hard
just trying to perfect those curved
shots you know
[Music]
also i like that you can't just go rapid
fire you gotta actually
wait hey go away oh i need a heart
i'm running away i'm running away
come on get out of here who want it who
want it
yeah oh oh oh
too close ooh come on i need to get this
guy so i can have a heart
no got him yeah oh and that was the
winning point
no oh wow oh wow
how'd you do how'd you feel i i might
me my team we had a great bonding
experience
we all played well together and now
we're pieces of chocolate apparently
what nice these winning screens are
what's crazy to me they're the best
oh hey i made the i made top of my team
and you meet top of yours nice
okay i mean i'll take that honey okay so
okay how how did this happen when
earlier
like what an hour ago you're like well
you know i don't know
i don't know how i'm gonna do in this
game look at you i mean
i have been practicing a little bit just
a little bit
you know you know uh so but you know i
think you did great
you uh you came in top of your team so
that's that's really awesome
that's awesome and i have to say i
really appreciate the abilities that
you guys gave me out there because that
push ability is awesome and
if i get someone really close to the
edge of a cliff
or the side of the map and i use that
push guess where they're gonna go
right off into the abyss into the abyss
it's my favorite it's okay so with crowd
play what says we got two crowd play
games remaining
yep and uh we have five in the queue so
we can actually get a couple more people
in this match
oh fantastic we're heading in and you
guys are going to get the option
to choose my ability again
so feel free to hit push but if you want
to see other abilities you could do that
too
so just so i have a better understanding
of it so when people want to jump in
let's say that there's four or five
slots available
those four or five slots get filled
obviously like the first people who jump
in
but then if i've pressed the button to
jump into the game
and someone was ahead of me once it's my
turn that that little button changes to
start right and i have to just press it
within a minute and then i can be in the
game yeah
oh yeah oh yeah and so this one is last
caster standing so this is a difficult
one
so i'm gonna need those abilities so i'm
counting on all of you out there
for that crowd choice poll quickly vote
give me a good ability all right all
right
bush is winning again okay this is which
is great bush's
push is still winning ooh don't stand
but we also have sprint coming in close
okay all right it's push off you gotta
push nice
yep so this is basically last last
caster standing so
best of luck to all of us
and i'm gonna cheat i'm using the
cannons if you shoot the cannons the
cannons just shoot
uh in whatever direction they're facing
ooh i'm out i'm out already see how
quick oh no go
oh yeah i got tv coupon and that person
was
awesome so great no austin how are you
doing
they tried to get me they tried to get
me oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna use you one shot oh
thank you i'll take that heart though
yeah
i appreciate it yeah you really gotta
watch out and grab those hearts where
you can
bye let's go don't forget about the
people who want it
who want it who want it huh
no okay oh ouchies ouchies
don't you got it austin you got it okay
oh got one okay
oh okay get that heart get that heart
goodbye
come on oh he's still got me cruz you
got him
[Music]
nice let's go
yeah yeah i got you y'all haven't played
the game before
and i got you haha
hey no that was a great game fantastic
game so what we got one more
we got one more oh i i did not do great
not disagreeing at all
[Laughter]
see you win some you lose some but
because they caught you off guard they
caught you okay they knew you were the
ringer
so they came after you at the beginning
that's the problem i couldn't get away
i was trying to i got stuck in a corner
i was like oh i got to get out of here
but nope
yeah that first part is just me running
away trying to find a power-up
too difficult also so i like the
customization stuff in this game so
obviously
uh everybody looks crazy and different
but
when we're going through like our
customizable options like hats hair
uh skin like all that stuff there's
there's so many options
yeah and that's what's really cool i
turned my guy into like a little
wintertime ice cream man yeah
and i just tried to make a mix of mr
meek seats
all right this is our last crowd choice
poll
guys hooked me up with those abilities
which you know what had i used in that
last game
i may have uh pushed the enemies away
but push is not an option
we gotta explain the mode so as we pick
up the
the currency here on the ground a bank
will open someplace
and then if your team has control of
that bank while you're in the circle
essentially like a king of the hill
situation you then are starting
depositing money in the bank and the
first team
with uh i believe 50 coins in the bank
wins yup gotta get and
uh you guys hooked me up with the wall
ability
so it's gonna allow me to put up a
little wall
oh i almost had that guy
man this guy i just happened to be in
the bank there oh i need that heart
oh no you're in the basement take it
from me dang it
thank you i'm gonna come back real soon
though
loot control of the bank get away from
me big push
cruise cruise back off me cruise
oh man cruz
we must protect this house we must
protect this house
this is nice no candy don't kill me yeah
push it i don't know if i can
i need a heart now give me a heart no
[Music]
a lot of business happening we got
ourselves a shootout
this is nuts all right i'm gonna go
through here
try to get some coins oh like i got
and then when you when you when you get
got you drop all your
uh coins right there so your teammates
can come through and yeah and your
pickups oh and your power-ups yeah
no he's a bummer
do you need some help buddy
cruz
okay please don't hurt me no
come here oh oh dang it i walked right
into it
i so i get mad at stuff like this
because i get
i'm so invested in the shootouts once
they start
firing up real crazy yep i know exactly
what you mean
i need to do a heart monitor on
oh bruce get away from me you almost had
that guy from like a distance
come on wow yep
wow okay all right bloodshine i see you
are you blue team or orange team i'm
blue team yeah
all right i need that heart
oh shoot wait no are you
oh oh oh no that makes the opposite team
yeah we are on opposition yeah
so by default you're you're blue team
when you're playing
oh yeah you're blue team to yourself
come on we're gonna get him this is a
close match
yeah oh and i got that heart
we need to get on that bank though guys
ooh austin i see you
no you don't no you don't that's not me
it's my it's my cousin
oh oh no
katie get away from me
why would you do this it was bloodshined
up you guys just ganged up on me you and
cruz
yeah bloodshot coming in for the last
shot you know what
bloodshine uh-huh i see you
oh i see you good hit that was a good
hit
i feel like i have nine
arch nimitzai in this match alone
coins all right we gotta stay in this
bank no we gotta stay in this fake get
him off the bank
open this door right now open the store
right now young lady
yeah get away austin don't do my diary
no
get out of here come on get out of here
no
sorry your team is solid your team is
stout your team is stout
you guys are 40
what right
all right okay nice nice get
oh oh no wait
get out of here whoa oh shoot get away
from me did i
push your wall away this shootout katie
i'm sorry i'm working on it no you're
this is so scary oh yo
okay you know what's funny i have got i
have got to
ah
[Laughter]
but it is one on one yes oh shoot shoot
i got it they're coming out let's go out
of here whoa
yeah get your boys out of here they want
to come through tell them to come get
the heat oh i got stuck
oh all right all right here we go are
you ready get away from you i'm gonna
get him no
you no stay away from me
who won did you guys win
no yeah
so i was using a vortex uh in those
first
uh few matches that's my bad i said push
but vortex uh is what i was using which
was
awesome awesome awesome this what a game
[Laughter]
you guys crushed it yeah you guys
crushed it this is sick
that was great all right oh man okay
well we have
so many more games to play so katie i'm
gonna let you set up the next one
and we'll see in a few minutes all right
see you soon
oh if you guys could feel my heart i'm
mad i don't have my heart monitored on
oh
oh i'm so invested all right let's get
back to some trailers
so now what we have is a brand new
announcement from stadia games and
entertainment
submerged hidden depths has launched on
stadia so let's check it out
[Music]
you
[Music]
so uh obviously i don't know what kind
of gamers you are i'm the kind of gamer
who
loves good uh detailed visuals visuals
guy
and that what he just saw submerged
hidden deaths visually
stunning and i it's honestly it's it's
available right now
you can play it it comes for free with
google uh
sorry with stadium pro just open up a
new tab pull out your phone
give it a go it looks good
and another one that we want to look at
it's another game that will be free for
stadia pro members is journey to the
savage planet hey there
it's me again martin tweed president and
ceo of kindred aerospace
in the last year journey to the savage
planet has launched over a million happy
explorers into space
their mission was simple explore a new
world catalog the flora
fauna and send the data back to kindred
hq it's a task that requires a great
deal of jumping
shooting scanning and a little bit of
filing paperwork
some have been very successful oh yeah
others have been
a little underwhelming we've spent the
last several months preparing something
new
exclusive to stadia we call it journey
to the savage planet
employee of the month edition this time
we're adding all of the super sweet
bonus content we added after the first
rockets launched
like photo mode and we're even including
a brief stop off on planet dlc one
where you'll get to meet our
distinguished competitors
viper industries
so don't miss this final rocket get out
there bring a friend explore
see the world only the very best of the
best will get a chance to partake in
this new round of space exploration
this time we're sending you with
everything we've got all the bells and
whistles
all the trimmings all of it and who
knows maybe one day your picture will be
hanging next to mine
journey to the savage planet employee of
the month edition
coming soon to stadia
just the music alone in the trailer
makes me smile so
make sure you don't miss the new
exclusive content in journey to the
savage planet
employee of the month edition that's all
you're trying to be anyway
trying to be that employee of the month
so come through with this employer of
the month edition
uh when it comes to stadia next year and
again
i've given you some information giving
you some trailers so that means
it's time for katie wilson to return
hey austin i'm super excited because
we're going to be playing some
dead by daylight one of my favorites
and if those of you out there are not
familiar with dead by daylight it is an
asymmetrical multiplayer game
inspired by all of your favorite horror
movies and series
four players are the survivors and their
job is simply
get out alive just survive uh but it's
not that easy
because the fifth player is going to try
to hunt them down
as the killer oh yeah it things get
really intense and dead by daylight but
guys
you want to know what's even cooler than
that dead by daylight
comes for free with stadia pro
oh yeah oh yeah and if you want to know
more about how all of that works you can
head on over to stadia.com and get the
whole
story um okay okay and so all you in the
chat if you're
planning on playing along from home with
the crowd play beta like i am right here
on my laptop i like that little intimate
dead by daylight experience i'm gonna go
ahead and refresh my uh
browser right now because it's a beta
you know we make sure everything's
working correctly
and uh we should be good to go if you're
all trying to jump in
and uh help your boy out yeah oh yeah
playing on a laptop you like it a little
scarier
i do it's nice right here you know uh
so first of all uh i'm gonna turn on
this crowd
choice poll right now cause you guys
at home the viewers you guys you're
gonna choose whether or not i play
as the killer or the survivor so
like austin said refresh that browser
you'll see the poll pop below the chat
i like playing as the killer i
specifically love the hillbilly
so i'm kind of hoping viewers out there
hook me up with my fave so i can just go
hunt everyone down with a chainsaw
you're you're high on killer right now
901 votes we got 74
for the killer go two seconds left uh-oh
two seconds a thousand over a thousand
votes we got the killer
73 for the killer 72
of youtube but guys we're gonna take
this one step
further i'm gonna hit this crowd choice
again and you guys are gonna choose
which
killer i play as all you do is type the
name of the killer in the chat
type the name in the chat
austin do you like saying as the
survivor or the killer i i'm a survivor
i know
you like the killers you're you're like
the hillbilly yeah right
oh yeah that's that's my go-to
why the hillbilly i just like the
chainsaw
i think honestly though i have the most
practice with the the hillbilly
so yeah i'm kind of hoping that's what
everyone hooks me up with but
we'll see i'm seeing the chat is flying
with the oni the blight the ghostface
the nightmare
people like the oni the nerd there's a
lot of everything
there's a lot of everything everything
but the hillbilly
now i see some hillbillies i see the
hillbilly in there a little bit
chainsaw yeah five seconds
[Music]
let's see what we got oh
all right this is going to be
quite terrifying uh do we get we have
the pig the pig one pig
all right that's fine guys that is fine
all right but next up we're gonna turn
on our crowd
play beta i'm gonna play as the pig as
you guys
suggested uh and i've never played as
the pig before so this is gonna be
interesting nice
uh i'm turning on that crowd play right
now click the button below the chat and
you guys
can see if you have what it takes to
escape with your life
there we go that's why they didn't
choose my my best character because they
want to win
they want a chance they want a chance
and uh
i have to admit i have to admit i may
have jumped into the crowd play so i am
gonna be trying to survive trying to
survive
while we're waiting for everyone to get
in i'm just gonna you know hook myself
up with some perks
let's make sure everything's working
correctly i'm going to
so so like i said i'm playing on my
laptop and so
to make sure i can still hear you and i
can hear uh what kind of
terrible things you're going to try to
do in this game i'm gonna pop this other
headphone in
nice nice so i was just working on my
loadout here
uh what do you like to go with you know
as i mentioned i i barbecue and chili is
a fun one
because then i can see where you guys
are you know very briefly
very briefly um i also like uh corrupt
intervention
which is nice and discordant of course
but
i gotta say this ebony memento mori
that's awesome that's your deal that's
your deal so you're
you seem well-versed uh
oh we have a full party we have a full
party so now we just need everyone to
ready up
this is intense i've never i've never
actually
uh played as this killer before so this
is going to be interesting
while we're waiting for them to ready up
uh how did you
become legend of katie oh
good question so uh one of my very first
gaming consoles ever was an n64
and uh my first n64 game i ever had was
the legend of zelda
ocarina of time just became my very
favorite game
uh and favorite game franchise uh i love
legend of zelda so i was like you know
legend of zelda but legend of katie
so it works i like it i like it
and that's i uh we talked about that so
i
feel like we're related in that sense i
have the triforce tattooed on my
forearm yes because it's it's it's the
best
it's the best okay so we're waiting
we're waiting for what two more people
to ready up
we're waiting on a skunk lord and
solarian to
ready up ready up guys so we can play
come on let's go ready up we're gonna
we're gonna win this one i feel this me
and chat
we're bonded right now okay we're right
here
hey you're not allowed to team up with
chat come on why not just hey
make sure you're not looking at the chat
so i can yeah i'm going to talk to them
on my phone
i'm going to load up the stream by phone
what are you going to type and run at
the same time yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly
you got a couple more seconds or we're
going to have to probably swap you out
with someone else if you don't ready up
we got one more we got one more come on
all right there we go ah nick of time
nick got it okay
one more oh and that's the chat coming
into my there we go
you have any strategies for this game
austin mine
my strategy is going to be uh sit
quietly in a corner
and try to scope out a generator from
where i'm
sitting and then just go do that because
otherwise check all the corners
yeah check all the corners
okay i'll tell everybody i'm i'm
strategizing with the chat
okay no no strategy
it's like it's just like the strategy
making
it's just me asking hitchhike what
should we do
[Laughter]
well you're probably going to be able to
see where i'm at so
we'll see i mean i i hope no i hope no
oh you me okay no i won't be looking at
it i'm not i'm not stream sniping no
no not at all actually so then let me
turn it off and we turn it up i just
told her to check the corners
this game is super dark as well so i'm
gonna have a hard time seeing you just
as it is
yeah all right all right
people saying i get my strategy away how
do you know that that wasn't a fake
strategy so that's what she would do
i can't see ah yeah good get over there
i don't think i've played on this map in
a long time
i feel like my character is breathing
way too loud
when he'd hurt him breathing way too
loud she's breathing way too loud
interesting cause i'm it's cause i'm
nervous
i gotta just talk all right
where are you at
oh okay so that's it's a no-no
oh oh wow
come on i gotta find my peoples
oh oh oh we're over by the lights you
see the flickering lights
go over there that's where we are all of
us yeah okay
all of us are congregating waiting for
you in one location don't don't look
anywhere else for us
someone knows what's up
it's so dark it's very dark so dark
killers need a flashlight oh no okay
see anything
i must be a heartbeat killer
whoa if it helps i haven't i i can't
tell
because i am so far away from you that
you don't even need to ever look for me
are you really i'm so far away from you
like i'm not even in the same map yeah
yeah yeah totally
i know someone was over here
oh let's see let's see let's let's
let's get this a little closer all right
all right
are you serious right now this
come on oh you're serious okay
goodness gracious no oh my god oh my
okay
oh okay okay how do i get down there
hmm ah
hello no don't take me
don't take me don't take me
don't take me don't take me don't take
me
no hooks no hooks don't take me don't
take me now
you're right i'll go
oh he's too short to put him on the hook
that's all right i'm coming for you oh
god
[Music]
all people i'm happy i found you first
it's very upsetting to me if i if i
wouldn't blow that generator it would
have been fine
twice you blew the gym
all right gosh this map is extremely
dark which makes it even more difficult
oh
hang on
whoa whoa who just saved you stop
working nobody
nobody saved me not a one person saved
me
i'm still on i'm still on the hook very
much so um
i know you're not
shh
i am i am i think i'm out of the game
honestly i think they i'm i'm dead
oh is is that the case yeah i'm not even
in anymore
someone's running
hmm
hi oh
here we go goodness it's so dark
oh shoot i lost him oh no what happened
that's what i get
that's what i get what happened
ouchies you hate to see it you know
yeah for sure it's easier to hide when
i can't see
hey austin how are things going for you
things things are going great
i'm still on the hook remember uh
no in fact i know you're not
no you're not
okay there we go don't don't pay
attention do you see anything at the
bottom of your screen
at the bottom of my screen like that
said that says that i'm alive
i can't find you guys this is difficult
this is difficult
oh you guys only have two generators
left though ooh i mean
is it the pig issue
it might be it might be not my
standard hillbilly self
he said i need my disgusting shoulder
wound in the chainsaw
the funny thing is is that you guys are
probably just running right past me
i will admit i've seen you a few times
yeah
it was very scary it was very scary
and you're gonna find me and congrats to
you
oh hello
dislike dislike what happened
i can't find you
[Laughter]
i'm damaging your generator why would
you damage
all the work that i've done
because i have to all right
why keep doing that i keep getting stuck
on stuff
do you keep going
[Laughter]
oh wait i'm so bad
oh my goodness
no it's so dark i can't uh
losing you uh what are the other people
doing
i don't know i haven't seen any i'll be
honest
i saw one i saw one person once oh shoot
i didn't mean to do that they helped me
off the hook
i don't know if okay it's a stream look
at the chat in a second
but does this come off as dang it
terrifying
as oh no
did they get you
shoot all right here we go here we go
you got it oh hi
person what is how did i not that
them oh and i keep losing them
oh goodness gracious
okay okay that's so that's not me
it's not you it's not me it's not me
you're the one that just blew the
generator over on the other side of the
map
no that's not me that's not you oh
specifically
hi i see you now all right you see who
you see who i saw a person but they're
running
they're running is it me and i'm gonna
probably lose them because i can't
see oh my goodness
so all right all right where are you i
know you're over here just gotta hit you
again but you probably keep healing
yourself
okay okay trixie
are there hmm okay
oh no
if i had my chainsaw i know then it'd be
it'd be a wrap
it'd be a different story
okay
whoa whoa what's happening uh
i don't know i i didn't the pig can turn
into this thing
i didn't even know i could do it what
are you turned into
uh like uh i don't know i'm roaring like
a lion
oops what you minotaur
perhaps
all right all right where'd you go
though where'd you go
we're doing this we're doing this
that was cool i didn't know i could do
that would you awesome okay
learning new things did you
did you get them um
i didn't
no i'm not
okay
i feel like this is ah
i'm here i see you
oh dang it
no no no leave me alone
oh no you guys got oh man i have no way
of winning this
whoa what was that oh we got the exit
yeah
jenna lost you guys oh had i known i
could do this cool ability
where's the exit though
oh no stay away from me stay away from
me
is this the exit am i going the right
way you're so close to me i think it's
behind you
no yeah i think the exits behind you oh
no what does this mean
no don't oh shoot i did the wrong thing
good good
no come back oh oh oh
oh friends friends friends friends
friends no
dang it now he's just messing with me
oh man that was great that was great oh
man good job austin i almost had you
there at the end almost
almost oh this is it's terrifying
katie it is it is this is terrifying
yep especially when you only learn how
to play as this killer halfway through
that yes so but that's that's a good
example of crowd choice working
in the in the chat's favor because they
got you
rather than you say i want the hillbilly
they go cool now we're gonna pick
something else so it's
a good way to show how much uh how much
control
the chat then has through crowd play
beta absolutely absolutely man
all right well i know we got one more
game to play so we'll let you go cue
that up and uh we're gonna talk about
some more stuff so see in a few katie
see in a few oh man okay
i don't i got to shake this off my you
these games are making my heart race
okay usa
we've got another game to play in just a
few minutes
uh katie will be back soon but while
she's doing that let's go take a look at
another
trailer so this is from uh for legendary
our jrpg from sega
valkyrie chronicles 4. i love a good
jrpg i get to sit down just take my time
and dump so many hours of my life
into a fantastic experience we got
another one coming to google stadia this
is awesome check it out
this is commander claude wallace squatty
the imperial forces are on the move
heading for your position ready to
engage
[Music]
[Music]
we have to unite as one otherwise we'll
never make it across the ice
we can do this
fine didn't take much
peace is a beautiful thing but it's
fragile
and once it's broken it can never be
made whole again
[Music]
moving out
it's time to end this
i'll do my part if you promise to do
[Music]
yours
i know i'm not worthy of this
responsibility
but i'll give all i've got to see it
[Music]
through
and gentlemen you know that you need
some things to do
you got some time and so this game
drops uh stadia next week so you can get
your hands on that at that point in time
like i said we give you a little bit of
information then we get back to it so we
are going to bring
back miss katie wilson
yes hello thanks again uh
this is really exciting uh because we
are going to pop
into some super bomberman r
online so guys just a quick reminder
be sure to hit that refresh on your
browser if you would like to hop
in and play with us this is gonna be fun
because this is a new twist
on a classic uh super bomberman r online
it's the old school
bomb combat you know but reimagined for
64
players right now it's
free to absolutely everybody on
stadia you don't even need a stadia pro
subscription
or trial it's free
you're saying this word over and over
again free free free free
free free my word absolutely
we are already getting a bunch of people
popping in here
guys yes that crowd play beta button is
below the chat
the game is free for absolutely everyone
with a stadia account no subscription
required so click it
join up and try to be the last bomberman
i'm trying i'm currently 53 of 54 in
line
yep and we are actually doing a full
64 player full-on bomberman battle
i'm excited oh wow okay so i'm just
looking at
like i said i'm looking at the stream
too to go through crowd play so uh
i'm now 44 of 186 in line
so i love like i i really enjoy the fact
that it's got a legit
cue so cause so many times i'll get
caught up streaming and be like
oh cool yeah we'll play with these four
people okay this person's next and just
by
you know a 15-minute game i just forget
and then the person i said was next
doesn't get a chance to play and i oh
crap i forgot
so this is great that there's a full cue
set up so you don't have to
fall into any of that stuff absolutely
and we're getting so close to filling
that cue
so really quickly while we're bringing
in the crowd austin i'm curious of
all the incredible things we've seen
here today what are you most excited
about
legit crowd play because i know i've
said it once earlier
but the fact that i could sit down and
instead of saying hey i want to play
this game with you guys the viewers on
stream
and then having to do the friend code
exchange and all of these like 900 steps
like
just press a button and just play and
the game is instantly there and the fact
like
i don't like the viewer doesn't have to
download the game in order to play it so
like
oh cool it's got stadia dope i don't
know how to make it but i have stadium
that means i have dead by daylight you
know
so uh that that's really cool to me
because it just makes the connection
between streamer and viewers so much
easier
i couldn't agree more i think that's
absolutely my favorite thing as well
being able to play with your favorite
streamer but as well as the
crowd choice polls those that's awesome
you know you really do get to influence
the streamers
uh gameplay which is really cool and uh
you can help them you can hinder them
works both ways
as we see nice hello everybody
everyone's reading hi all right we have
two more spots open until we hit okay
let's go
four let's go this is gonna be madness
this is good i love it i love it
but this is such a great game to be able
to play uh
with your audience uh because you can
fit 64
four people which is awesome yes and so
if you guys haven't played
uh played this version of the game yet
so you've got it's essentially like a
battle royale style so you've got a
bunch of different states with a dump
bunch of different bombermen on them
and after a certain amount of time
passes gates open up and you can
jump to a different area and so uh you
got like what i think it's a 10 second
countdown before the stage locks and you
have to play against those people
so uh so it's pretty cool almost like a
choose your own adventure of who you
want to be
uh blown up by
nobody yeah hopefully yeah
you have any uh strategies advice for
this game
um so if you can find someone and put
them in the corner if you can put baby
in the corner you're good to go
nice cause then they they can't escape
from bombs on both sides so
uh more easier said than done obviously
but if you can get that you're good
my uh own piece of advice is just don't
get blown up by your own bomb
i've done that frequently frequently
i feel like as long as you don't get
blown up by your own bomb then you're
doing all right
you're doing okay it's it's sound advice
so guys if you're not seeing that uh
crowdplay beta button
just refresh your browser real quick it
is just below the chat you can click it
and join
the cube to play we have two more spots
open
yes and remember if just because you're
in line you don't automatically jump in
once you have clicked to be a part of
the line and then it's actually open
you then have to click that button again
to actually jump into the game so it
gives you 60 seconds to go ahead and
click that button to jump in
and if you don't then i believe it moves
on to the next person in line yep
we have room for one more one more lucky
person
come on come on press the button
press the button
oh we're good all right we're doing it
oh let's go i'm going to be doing uh the
greatest of casting
on this well not maybe not the greatest
of casting but i will be casting
this event because the chat beat me into
the game
all right saying there we go
oh match the rules
okay let's see let's see we're getting
this set up making sure
everybody can get in making sure
everybody that wants to get in
can't get in let's do it let's do this
ooh let's go
this is going to be wild chaos i'm so
ready
what i really wanna wanna see is i wanna
see
this played by 64 people that are all
streaming
so you can see all 64 feeds at the same
time oh my gosh that would be
that'd be awesome though yeah
all right here we go
and you've gone with pink great
selection i did
great selection what about you i i
wasn't able to get in the the chat beat
me in
no but that's but that again i think is
a great example
of the fact that as long as you're
you're not just watching the stream
you're
waiting to interact with the stream so
now uh you've got to be on your on your
p's and q's
in order to get in exactly well this is
good for me because you could coach me
through this
got you okay i'll just be go left
go up no really i could use all the help
i could get
okay collect all of the uh things that
you can as you blow up the bricks
that that'll be step one for us
okay and you're pink you're up at what
the top left yeah
good okay so you got the skates you're a
little bit faster now
just trying not to get blown up mm-hmm
yeah this is smart strategy you just
keep to yourself for a little bit
they're coming for you gonna try to trap
you into something
don't let them trap you
so you got uh 20 seconds until you uh
go to the next area as long as you last
you'll be good and then eventually it'll
whittle down to sudden death
all right all right all right oh they
are trying to trap me
oh here you go see you're fine you're
fine okay i'm just trying to stay away
from everyone yeah
you're great all right okay movement
phase so you can either go up or to the
right
or you can or you can stay in there
oh yeah don't stay in there no
[Music]
[Laughter]
you got the life it's vicious get out of
here
ah thank you for trapping me there oh
wrong
i need a chainsaw i don't know what is
it the hillbilly he
yeah it's the hillbilly hillbilly's
maddie didn't get picked and dead by
daylight so he's coming back to get you
don't get trapped you're staying there
stay there just stay there no i'm out of
here
yeah good out of here
nice oh
you're in the top 32 top 32 let's go
let's go
okay i don't like this scary bunny thing
oh oh in the chat in the chat they said
uh
go to a room with the star with the star
i don't
see it oh gosh oh and corey explains
pink's
stats are fixed so the only thing she
can pick up are kick pierce or rubber
okay good to know good to know
all right see again we got people in the
chat playing the game and then people in
the chat giving us advice
on things in the game that we might not
know see this is
what a synergistic relationship you know
everybody wins
leave me alone ah okay
oh no you're in there with you're in the
with the chainsaw man
no you oh
no oh no oh no
that's what you call stream top 32. we
want to watch and see who
he has stream sniping yeah uh you want
to watch and see who wins
oh yeah for sure man
that was fun though that was yes and so
also this guy's pro he's got a chainsaw
this is a cool way so obviously if
you're if you're playing games with chat
you've got 63 other
people from your chat in a game that's a
cool way to do
uh like a little tournament for your for
your viewers
whether you have like oh cool like
giveaways or something or just for clout
that's i'm into this
it's really important i love all these
because you know getting getting the
opportunity to play with your viewers
is really awesome no more having to spam
the chat like please can i play
what's your gamer tag how can i play
it's like no you just hit a
it's so easy and so can you see when
you're in viewer mode can you jump
around to the different
uh different stages with any buttons
oh maybe
oh all right all right okay
yeah that's cool so we can see where the
action is
are you just gonna follow chainsaw bunny
stay away from chainsaw bunny
yeah i feel like anybody who on a whim
was like hey do you randomly want to
play bomberman like oh yeah i got my
chainsaw bunny skin it's like oh you
play play
you play bomberman you like you play for
real we're ready for this moment
yeah oof
wow
wow i love it yeah no i've got to say
the people playing right now know what's
up they know how to play
they're experienced players this is
awesome yeah
it's cool to watch the talent level
drop it like 15 bombs at a time
this is one of the this is one of those
is gonna go sudden death yeah i have a
feeling
i see in my head i was like oh yeah this
will be
this would be fine and then all of the
uh
bomberman killers came out oh yeah
we didn't know we had we had the
world-class bomberman team have the pro
the pro league right here
[Laughter]
that's a good you know oh oh chase on
bunny
we got uh gwen says i've never played
this game before i was out so quick but
again
now you've played this game and all you
have to do is click a button
yup like how dope is that cause how many
times again has
someone been on stream like oh come and
play this oh well hold on i haven't
played it i gotta go
download it it's like no you don't you
just click the button then you're good
times that's the best just click and
play
yeah plus you don't have asking the
streamer like hey
which which you know platform are you
playing on does can we play together
it's like yeah you just hit the button
yeah
you're like bro i'm on stadia with that
wasabi controller oh
i know right that wasabi controller it's
fire i i highly i implore you all who
are watching once this is done
when you're going to uh go check out the
stadia controllers look at that wasabi
control the regular controller is
gorgeous
it's fantastic that wasabi though
looking good in the club
all right this is the five people left
yeah the last square
this is it this is the finals who's
gonna win
chad okay can we see names no we can't
see names
so okay uh we'll call them uh
chainsaw bunny there i can show names
okay show names all right chad who do
you think's gonna win
let's see it there i mean
i don't want to root for chainsaw bunny
because they took me out
but also i want to root for chainsaw
bunny i know but i also want to root for
skunk lord
just because of the name i know oh y'all
think
okay sk ramo mike
okay let's see oh the money's on remote
oh down to three
bunnies out wow yeah
sk gamer oh oh
oh he's got the chains off oh buddy's
out
oh no all right oh no bunny's got a life
he's still got a life
oh okay okay just out here laying bombs
like eggs like his easter come on
just just giving out gifts need an egg
basket
the ball
he had another life oh he's got another
life okay okay
oh oh my god oh oh hilarion and sk gamer
okay
okay out of these two right here skr
solari
i'm so invested it's i am i'm
very easily stressed out this is
stressing me
oh they both both sk gamer
oh wow wow wow
wow that's
that was incredible that was amazing
those incredible c4 player
super bomberman are online free with
stadia
oh my goodness
this is this has been great katie that
was the uh the last game that we're
gonna play today
thank you so much for setting all this
stuff up and doing it and giving us all
this information
on crowd choice and crowd play beta of
course austin thank you so much for
having me i had a blast
and if you guys want more stadia games
with me you can drop by my youtube
channel legend of katie where i'm going
to be playing it real
soon yeah oh wait do you happen to be on
twitter and instagram by chance i am on
twitter i'm at the katie wilson on
twitter and
katie wilson picks on instagram yep
that's me perfect thanks perfect austin
well this has been great
and uh we'll catch you next time katie
see you all right see ya
all right so hope you guys enjoyed
seeing crowd choice and crowd play beta
in action and do not forget that there
are other really amazing ways that
stadia
uh makes your games even better like
stream connect
now this lets you see through your
teammates eyes in co-op and so
i know i know you've been situation
where you're playing a co-op game
you need some help something's happening
and you're thinking you're screaming
where is my squad
well this will make games like ghost
recon break point and division two and
uh orcs may die or sorry orcs must die
three
very incredible because you can see
through your teammates eyes in that
co-op experience so no more excuses
and if you like crowd play it works on
many more games on stadiums such as
samurai showdown
mortal kombat 11 fighting games my
wheelhouse you know i'm sad
and again you don't have to go through
that whole rig of a row of oh what's
your friend code or your
your id and all that stuff um you can
just
click the button and jump in to those
fighting games playing people but then
you can
also you can also jump in on games like
borderlands 3
so running around these borderlands
picking up loot doing all sorts of crazy
stuff you can just click the button
jump in with your favorite streamer and
then crowd choice
also let you decide your favorite
streamers and game choices in games like
baldur's gate 3. so again just for that
recap you can either help
or hinder your favorite streamer i know
that my people want to
hinder me because then i freak out and
my heart rate goes up to 170
and it's very entertaining and funny for
them extremely stressful for me
so use your power wisely but to keep
things rolling along we have another
special guest because joining me
right now to talk about one of the most
exciting new franchises of the year
immortals phoenix rising which is
available today
on stadia we've got ubisoft's one and
only
scott phillips hello claire
glad to be here ah great awesome that
you're here we'd love to have you
i'm gonna jump right into it okay so for
you this is the launch day
what is this like for you you have to
have a million emotions swimming around
in you right now how is that
yeah well i mean it's the culmination of
uh two years of work from hundreds of
people
lots of decisions lots of uh tough
things we had to go through
uh but now we can sort of let
our breath out we can take a deep breath
we can just
let the stress go and you know our baby
is born and it's out there and now we
get
uh to see how everybody plays with the
mortals phoenix rising
and i imagine just like a baby you at
one point saw crawling walking and now
you see it running and you're so proud
and i know that when you were making it
there were most likely some things in
there
that uh that you interpreted a certain
way and really really touched you so
i'm curious as to what's maybe one of
those things that you're really
uh proud of that you're excited for
people to now be able to experience
i mean there's there's a ton of things
we're proud of obviously the the whole
game how it all came together
i think the the combination of all the
great gameplay that we have with the
over-the-top mythological combat this
great risky traversal and these
challenging puzzles
uh is awesome and then on top of that
you have this great narration from zeus
and prometheus the
the uh the our main narrators in the
game but you get to go on this journey
with phoenix uh
and you get to see how this character
grows from someone who isn't sure about
their future
isn't sure that they can be what this
prophecy says they're going to be but
then
you as the player get to go on this
journey and help them achieve that it's
it's really a special game
well it sounds like it's got a lot of
lore and like you said kind of based in
that greek mythology
uh lore as well and so i i love i
love love love mythology and i love it
for the same reason i love video games
because
you get to go into these crazy
experiences with these larger than life
characters
and it seems like the way this game
flows it might be a cool intro for
people who don't necessarily know
a lot about greek mythology and so was
that something that you guys
uh felt was important when you were
creating this the story arc with all
this lore
yeah for sure i mean when we started on
assassin's creed odyssey five years ago
i felt i knew nothing about greek
mythology but then as we got into it as
we started hearing these names of you
know cerberus and minotaur
and zeus and hermes and prometheus you
recognize like oh okay i actually know a
lot of these names
and then with immortals phoenix rising
our goal was to bring that mythology
really front and center
and you know bring a 21st century sort
of spotlight onto it and
tell these tales as they were told back
then 3000 years ago
of these gods who are more like people
they're not perfect
they're not this unachievable perfection
they have uh
problems as well and so in immortals
phoenix rising we really expose that
and expose the journey that they go on
to sort of
see themselves as more full people
accepting uh the issues that they have
as gods
well this game sounds awesome it looks
incredible the lore
sounds so so interesting so i'm glad
that people have a chance to
to experience it now and everybody
watching you can even try it before you
buy it there's actually a link
in the description box go ahead and
click that and it'll take you right to
the immortals phoenix rising demo
exclusively
on stadia and scott i know you're very
busy man like we said it's launch day
very busy day for you we won't take up
any more of your time i just want to say
thank you so much for joining us
my pleasure i was glad to be here of
course and everybody do yourselves a
favor and go get your hands on immortals
phoenix rising
right now and so
as we pass through time this journey
that we go on together it's time to
start wrapping things up a little bit so
just to look back at what we've talked
about today we played
a bunch of games with legend of katie
who's fantastic and all of you
we got the inside scoop on immortals
phoenix rising from scott phillips
and we checked out some exciting new
games from stadia games and
entertainment and speaking of upcoming
games
i'd feel remiss if i didn't talk about
cyberpunk 2077
is right around the corner in just one
week on december 10th you'll finally be
able to hit the streets of night city
and live out your craziest cyberpunk
fantasies
and if you pre-order it now you'll also
get a free stadia premiere edition
so you get cyberpunk 2077 a stadia
controller
and a chromecast ultra and i would say
all together that's a pretty sweet
holiday gift for yourself because as we
are going to be getting gifts for other
people you got to take care of yourself
too
it's the holiday season go ahead and
treat yourself you deserve
but the fun does not end there because
this is just the beginning of several
days of stadia live streams where you
can play along with creators using crowd
choice and crowd play beta
you can go to stadia's twitter and see a
schedule of all the streams you can join
when they go live
and we've got some new streams coming
this week some of your favorite
streamers are streaming outcasters
dead by daylight and super bomberman are
online
on their channel starting tomorrow now
again
you can get the whole schedule on
stadia's official twitter twitter
so mark your calendar and see these
creators streaming stadia live on
youtube
all throughout the holidays
and now ladies and gentlemen
it has been a pleasure a joy being here
with you all today
i'm so happy i got to spend the morning
with my fellow gamers
this right here it's mine now
staying with me but i still need that
wasabi one
and y'all need that wasabi one too go
ahead and get both of them
but overall be sure to follow stadia on
youtube
twitter instagram and facebook make sure
you follow me on twitter instagram
austincreedwins both names and check me
out on youtube
at uh up up down down happy holidays to
each and every one of you
and i'll see y'all on stadium
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you